お願いします えっと あの
特にあの初期仏教といえば
この大変あの 一番大事な概念の一つとして
考え方の一つとして このドッカっていう言葉がございます
これについて まあかなりいろんなところで
この場所でも何回も同じテーマでお話をしましたし
今同じテーマでリピートなんですね
で 一番最初に喋った時は一応まとめて喋りまして
リピートになるとそれぐらい大体大雑把で喋ってはしますけど
もしかすると四回 五回ぐらいかな
同じテーマで喋りましたと思います
で こういうことを私が考えるようになった理由がありまして
ある 私も勉強途中だからね
まあいろいろ方々は仏教について語るときはまあちょっと聞いてはみますけど
日本で一番ものすごい人気のある
ものすごい大事というか
有名というかね で すごい宗教家として思われるある方がね
NHK でちらっとこういうことを言ったんですね
釈迦がね 大したことは言ったわけじゃないんだと
うーん 釈迦 ただまあ全ては空やと言っただけでね
もっとすごい教えがあると
と言ったんですけど だから私は考えたのは
この方は釈迦さんよりすごいことを知ってるでしょうね
ということを思ったんですけど
まあその方が言ってることは
やっぱり日本では誰でも大変信頼してね
信じていらっしゃるし
もう何千人も弟子たちもいて
で それから調べてみたんですね
このすごい教えは何なのかと
それで一つ面白かったのは
この世界の平和のために断食する
どこかに隠れて で 面白いことに
それでも世界平和は成り立ったんです
もう今 世界ではどこにも戦争も何もないんです
で 大げさにその方がまあ 1週間か断食しましたからね
それでその問題も解決しましたし
それからあの日本の社会の方々にいろんな問題がありまして
病気になったり あるいは死に別れになってね
そこですごく神経がね
まあガタガタになって落ち込んだり
悲しかったり 会社倒産して頭が狂ってしまっちゃって
どうどこに怒れてとかね
そういう方々は結構そちらに行くんですね
行ったらまあなんと素晴らしいか
もう直してくれるんです
で 一つ煩悩 神業を捨棄をしなさいと
それでみんな問題解決しているんです
だからまあ大丈夫やと思いますけど
ですから 私が考えたのは
まあそれぐらいのインチキやらね
くだらんことで まあ迷信って迷信なんですけどね
それぐらいのことで 釈迦なんだか何だ大したことは言ってないんだ
まあただ空と言っただけですよと
で 確かにその方はもう徹底的にこの世の中の喜び
欲 すごく認めてあげるんですね
女の人々がね 旦那が浮気して困ってるので
だから何が悪いんですかと
素晴らしいと あなたもやってくださいというふうな話なんですけど
名前はもう残念ながらね
言ったらまあ私は訴えられるかもしれませんだから
まあ一応そこは話に関係ないんです
まあただ なんで私はこのドッカという言葉について二
三回喋りました あくまでもこれ
私個人の主観的な感情で
皆様方は別にそんな話は聞きたくはないかもしれません
あまりにもつまらなくて
まあドッカっていうことが
まあパーリ語でドゥッカというんですね
で まあそれはごく一般的な言葉で
苦しみという意味ですよ
言葉にはそれほど複雑な意味があるわけじゃなくて
当時インドで使っていたどんな単語
どんな言語でも 言語というか分かりませんだけど
いろいろたくさんインドでは言葉使ってますから
どんな言葉でも大体まあ苦しいという苦しみということに
ドゥッカという言葉を使っていたんです
うんだから一般的な世界で
みんなこれは苦しいんだ
これは大変だとかね これは悲しいんだとかね
そういうことがまあたまたまでも人生にはあります
あの ですから このたまたまでも
ちょっとした悲しいこと
苦しいことがあったら
ああ これがドゥッカだよというふうに言うんですね
その言葉をお釈迦様使って
この偉大なる真理として
語り始めたんですね で
違うところは お釈迦様がこれが自分がもう発見したものだと
私が偉大なる真理を発見しましたと
初めて人類初めて発見しました
誰もこんなことを発見していなかったと
それが何でしょうかと
ドッカであると まあそう言われると
なんかお釈迦様に笑いたくはなりますね
だってみんなまあそれぐらいドッカでしょうと
苦しいでしょうと 大変でしょうというぐらいは知ってるし
で まあドッカに何か特別な何か一言葉入れてあれば
それはそれでもよろしい
そういうことでもなく
単なる  ドッカという言葉で
まあそんな何が発見したんでしょうかと
という気持ちにもなります
ですから まあ後になってくると
お釈迦様がドッカだけで言ったら笑われちゃいますから
まあもうちょっとその言葉を伸ばしてみたんですね
ドッカ アリアサッチャということで伸ばしてみたんですね
アリアっていうのは一般人ではないという意味で
聖者 聖なるということで
で いわゆる優れている
うん 一般レベルを乗り越えている
サッチャっていうのは真理
まあそれで このアリアサッチャといえば
一般的にみんな言ってる
この人生苦しい 大変という意味と差がついたんですね
そこで問題はこの 我々知っているドッカとお釈迦様おっしゃっているドッカってどんな差でしょうかというぐらいのことで
まあそれほどたくさんことはしゃべらなくても
すごいできるだけ早く教皇は終了したいとは思っているし
ですから まあ淡々と早く喋りますが
まあ普通の世の中である
この まあ例えばね まあマラソンを走ってるんだと
まあ半分ぐらい走ったところで
まあ結構きついと まあその時も使える言葉というのは
やっぱり苦しいと 苦しかったということは使わなくてはいけないんですね
で まあそういうふうに日常生活の中で
苦しいっていうことが出てくる
で ただ それで まあそれでお釈迦様おっしゃった苦しみという偉大なる真理でしょうかと
そうでないというために
お釈迦様はドッカアリエサッチャという言葉を使っているんですね
何でお釈迦様がこの苦しみであること
これ偉大なる真理でしょうかと
ということが経典でこう言ってるんですね
今までこれ知らなかったと
今までこれ知らなかったんだから苦しんでいたんだと
それでこの苦しいということが分かってから
全てのものはドッカであると
そういうことをもう分かった瞬間で
自分の心は完全な安らぎを体験したんだと
それだけじゃなくて これからも自分の心には微かにでも悩み苦しみが生まれないと
もう最終的な平安 自分でもう平安という境地をもうに入ってしまいましたと
それでやるべきことはやり終えたと
なすべきことは成し終えたと
えーと 育てるべきものは育てて終えたと
これからはやることはなくなったと
すべて終わったと ということでまあおっしゃってますね
ですから このドッカっていうことを知ることが
お釈迦様にとっては大変な発見でしたし
普通の方々にとってはこんな当たり前の日常のことでね
で もっとすごい真理を語ってくれるんだったらね
まあ面白いんだけど なんだそんなくだらんことかというふうに思うかもしれませんですけどね
だからそこら辺 少々お考え
考えてみましょうと まああの
どこから始めればいいか
ちょっと それで仏教に対するいろいろ批判のところがございまして
まあ時に 大乗仏教に対して学者が何をおっしゃっているかあまりわかりませんし
だから私はこの我々の仏教に対して
特に西洋でいろんなたくさんの研究論文を書かれていますからね
そちらの考え方から見ると
あまり仏教に対しては好意的ではないんですね
仏教自体は悲観的で 気をつけて言うんだけどね
どちらかというと悲観的であると
で 世界をね まあ生きていることを
我々のこの世の中を認めていないんだと
暗い教えだよというふうに
まあなんとなく言っちゃうんですね
で それ他の宗教と比べて言うんですね
ですから 大変喜びを楽しみを語っている他の宗教と比べてみると
仏教は少々悲観的ですと
それで私は考えたのは
生きること 人生やらね
そういうものは大変素晴らしいと
と楽観主義で語った哲学はありますかと
宗教がありますかと いろんな宗教がありますね
まあ古い まあね まあすごい古い宗教からね
現代宗教までたくさん宗教があります
世の中で その宗教の世界では
人間について語っています
どんな宗教でも人間のことを語っています
でね イランでね 昔あの
なんとかという宗教がありましたね
ゼンダヴェスタという聖書も今もありますけど
ゾロアスターニズムというね
まあインドになると 今
現代ヒンドゥー教というね
昔は複雑な宗教いっぱいありまして
バラモン教とかね ありまして
今は全部まとめてヒンドゥー教というんですけど
お釈迦様ともうちょっと先輩でジャイナ教というものがありまして
インドでね それでまあそれに比べて西洋の方というか
中東の方にも まあユダヤの人々を信仰しているユダヤ教やらね
まあキリスト教のもう数えられないほど宗派たくさんありまして
それからイスラム教という最近の宗教があります
そちらの中にもいろいろ宗派がありますが
で いろいろあります だから生きることはすごいすごい素晴らしいことであって
純粋に大変楽なものだとと言っていますかと
誰かが ですから よく見ると別におんなじことを言っているんですね
まあ生きることが大変だとという立場で語っているんです
何かしなくちゃいけないんだと
この何かしなくちゃいけないと言っていることが宗教なんです
キリスト教の方々は我々にあんた方はそんな調子だったらダメですよと
何かしなくちゃいけないんだよと言っているんですね
イスラム教にしたっても
そんなことで冗談じゃないとダメですよと
危険だよと 何かしなくちゃいけないんだと
その何かしなくちゃいけないという部分が宗教なんですね
ですから 修行方法やらお祈り方法やら
何か人がやらなくちゃいけないと言った途端
もうこの世の中のことにケチつけてます
別にお釈迦様だけじゃないんです
例えばイスラム教だったら
1 日 5回お祈りしなくちゃいけないんですね
で そういう一つ  1 日 5回神様にお祈りしなさい
神様のことを思って感謝しなさいと言われたら
それだけで我々の生きている世界をもうケチつけてます
いわゆるお祈りしないならば
それが危険 危険ですからね
何か大変なことになりますから
ですから この世界は悲観的に見たのはお釈迦様だけじゃないんです
で 全ての宗教で一応考えてみると
一応組織的なシステム的な宗教であるならばね
まあそういうふうになっているんですね
それでもお釈迦様によれば
お釈迦様が最初にドッカの真理を発見して
それでお釈迦様が最初に悟りを開いたと
今まで誰にもできなかったと
というところが違うところなんですね
だったらドッカをいわゆる人生はね
まあ苦しいやと全ての宗教で言ってるんだから
まあ誰でも同じではないかなと
どんな宗教でもね まあ何か同じではないかなという論理成り立ちますけどね
で  いかなるものでもね
まあドッカでしょうと
で お釈迦様の違うところは二分化しなかったんですね
で 宗教によると この世の中はとんでもない悪の塊で
あの世はもうそれに正反対で
善の塊なんですね 二分化していますね
例えば人間の世界と天国という 2つに分けて考えちゃうと
人間の世界はもう苦しみばっかしで
まあ天国に行けばすべて万事解決だと
それ二分化しているんです
だからこっち危険だから
じゃああっち行きましょうと
まあ言葉上ではそういうふうにも使わなくてはいけないんだからね
たくさん単語もないんだからね
しょうがないところもありますけど
お釈迦様の違うところは
その二分化がないんです
こっちもあっちもどっかだよと
で そういう二分化していないところが問題違うところなんですね
だから天国に行ったっても
やっぱりしょうがないんですね
だからお釈迦様はこれ言いたがっていたんですね
普通にお釈迦様を知っていた宗教の人々が
天界 天国 何でもいいんですけど
あの世というところにね
そこに行けば安心だよと
そちらに行くための努力をしていたんですね
お釈迦様は まあまとめて全部ドッカだよと
二分化できないということで
2つまとめて 1つ白い
1つ黒いとは言えない
一切はドッカであると
だから一切回向という言葉もございます
ございますでしょうに
二分化しなかったんですね
そこをわかったところで何ですね
まあ発見しましたと もうこれで心の安らぎを得たんだと
というのは  そこら辺ですね
この違うところがね 偉大なる真理というのは
あまりこの細かく説明したってもね
皆様方にそんなことをいちいち言わなくたってもいいんじゃないかなという気持ちになりますのでね
では 次のポイントで考えましょう
私たちは生きることは苦しみであると知ってますかと
生きること 苦しい 大変だと知ってますかと
それは知らないと思います
私たちは生きることは必ず幸せだと
今ちょっと文句あっても
そんなものはどうったことはない
確実に幸せになるんだと
幸せそのものだと と一般的には思っているんです
が 違うところは認めてない
だからそこら辺 人間と語りにくいところなんですね
心の中に思っていることとは反対のことを堂々と言うんですね
だから 本にあるものをみんな語るもの
みんなの学問的な知識っていうのは
心にある考え方の反対なんですね
だからすごく困っているんですが
普通に言えば まあ本当はそういうことなんですね
だから人生は大変だと
生きることは苦しいやと
ひとかけらも認めたくないんです
絶対的にこれ楽しいやとは思っているんです
思って そんなこと言っちゃったら馬鹿にされるかもしれません
だから まあなんとかなんとか
まあそうだな やっぱり大変ですよとかは言います
言うんだけど 心の中でそんなことありっこはないんだと
ですから 人々がなんとか悩み事があったら
会社の問題があったら
家庭の問題があったら
で 人間関係で何か問題があったら
いろいろ偉い知識の方々に言ってカウンセリングを受けるでしょうに
で カウンセリングを受けたところで
まあ何言ってくれるかと
というと やっぱりまあまあ
それぐらいのことでね
そんな気にする必要はないんだと
もう大丈夫やと これ ちょっとしたこのちょっとしたことでしょうと
人生はもう素晴らしく
まあ幸せやと  他の例がないかな
例えば桃一つ買ってきて
これどうしようか 困った
大変だと 何でしょうか
食べられないんだと なんで食べられないかと
この皮はね ちょっとギザギザみたいな状態で
なんかちょっと毛虫の皮膚みたいな感じでね
なんかちょっとそれで悩むぐらいのことですかね
この桃の皮だからね それは自分の爪ででも脱げるでしょうに
あ それ大したことはない
こうやってこの皮を剥いてくださいと
そうすると美味しい桃食べられますよと
それが世の中の考え方なんです
世の中の人々がドッカだよと言っている苦しみが
パイナップルの皮とは違うんです
パイナップルは  だから私の国の果物言ったって意味がないんですけどね
栗のトゲトゲついてますね
栗の皮のようなものじゃないんです
栗っていうのは３つありますね
皮が 一番外にもうとんでもない危険物で
もう触ったら怪我する
それはいくらか自動的に割れますから
もう悩まなくてもいいでしょう
そんなことで すぐ中の種が落ちてきますね
でももう一つ硬い殻がそれで
もありますね それもあの
まあちょっと慣れたところですぐ皮むけるんです
もう 2枚目 それ抜いてもまたまた時々
まあまたあの緑黒い茶色のもうちょっと膜がありますからね
それちょっと苦いんですからね
まあそれもちょっとしたことで抜くことできます
ですから 栗そのものを見て
ああ 大変だ これ危険だ
触ったら怪我するんだとかね
と思う必要はないんです
皮を抜いて もうやり方があるんだと
で それが一般的な人生論なんです
この世の中の苦しみについてみんな語っているのはそれぐらいのことなんです
まあ桃に桃に皮がついていたっても
そんな気にすることがないんです
指でもちょっと砂で自分の指で全部皮をむけるんです
リンゴの皮はそれはできませんですけどね
だから桃っていうのはすごくいい例えなんです
残念ながら  お釈迦様の教えはそれと違うんです
それはたとえがないんですね
むいてもむいても 何も得られなくなっちゃいますよと
それはこの誰かが玉ねぎの種がすごく美味しいですよ
玉ねぎよりも 言って この玉ねぎの皮をむいてくださいと
そうするとすごい美味しい種がありまして
それ食べてみてください
これこそ世界でこれほどごちそうがないんだと
その話に乗せられた人が
玉ねぎの皮をむくわむくわむくわむくわ
まあ何か最後に何か見つかるんですかね
皮だけでしょうに 種がないんですね
お釈迦様がおっしゃっている苦しみは何かそんなものなんですね
我々表面的に感じる苦しみをなくしてみたら
またもう次にまた一つ出てきて
それもいてみたら またもう一つ出てきて
それもいてみたらまたもう一つ出てきて
結局苦しみを抜けては抜けてはと
まあもう退けて退けてというか
乗り越えて乗り越えて
行っても行っても 次から次へと出会うのはすべてドッカですよ
だから全体的に苦しみだよというのはお釈迦様の教えで
世の中の考え方は桃の話で
で そういうことをなぜ言ったかというと
お釈迦様はこの法句経でこう言うんですね
すべてのこの世の中のこの組み立てているもの
できているもの 一切の現象がドッカであると知ったならば
それだけのことで人間は一切の苦しみを乗り越えるんだよと
乗り越えるという それで一切の苦しみについて
この について この何といいますか
この嫌悪感というかね
まあ悼むことになりまして
一切の苦しみを悼むようになりまして
それで清らかな道 聖なる道というか
この真理に出会いますよと
これこそ悟る道だよと
で まあドッカぐらいは苦しみぐらいはわかってるんだ
そんな単純なことをわかってるんだと
なんで単純ですか？と思う人々がほとんどなんですけど
悟りを体験した人は一人もない
だからこのドッカという言葉っていうのは
もう大変な お釈迦様から見れば大変な言葉で
それわかったらもう悟っているんです
それで別に何に努力する必要ないんで
もうそれで終わり 終了
卒業 だからじゃあいくらいろんな哲学で
いろんな師匠で いろんな話があるんだけど
すべてやっぱりドッカドッカだ
苦しいですとかね あるんだけど
そういう人々が悟っているんでしょうかと
例えば仕事に疲れて疲れて
本当にもう生きるってことは大変だなと
まあなかなか大変だとと言っても
じゃあ悟ってますかね
で 人間の生き方 次に考えてみましょう
人間っていうのは仕事は大変
ものすごくストレス溜まる
胃に穴もうあっちこっち穴まで開けてしまう
髪の毛はもうどんどん落ちちゃう
大体実際の年よりはまあ 10年老けている
それで夜も寝られない
もう仕事のことで それでそれでもなんとか苦労して頑張っても
思った通りの結果にならない
そういうふうに この全てまあいいことばっかりかもしれませんだけど
それでも人間っていうのはとにかくそれでも努力するんですね
だから努力して努力して
とにかく頑張っちゃう
どんな不幸に出会っても
やっぱりとにかく頑張って
もうチャレンジをして先へ行くんですね
では考えてみてください
そうやって乗り越えた人が一人でもいますかと
だから次から次へと迷路の中に壁にぶつかるだけでしょう
人生ということ自体が一つの迷路のようなもので
一旦入ってみたら 壁行き詰まり
じゃあ右に曲がってまずかったと
じゃあまた戻って また左に曲がってみる
じゃあもうまた壁 じゃあまっすぐに行けば
まあまた壁 だから出口ありますかと
人生のという迷路の出口がお釈迦様おっしゃっている悟りでありまして
そういう普通の人々は
いくら仕事はいくら苦しくても
私は負けませんと もう頑張ってみるんだと
それで徹底的には頑張る
全然負けたくはない どんな苦労したっても
とにかく頑張ると 時々
例えば脳出血やらそういうもの
突然倒れちゃったらね
もう半身もう不自由になっちゃうんですね
脳もかなりいかれてしまうんですね
それでも頑張る人々は
ものすごい もう想像できないほどリハビリやってやって
まあこちら半分動かないんだから
言葉なんか喋れません
それでも運動して 運動して
リハビリをして して して
普通の健康な人から見れば
このもう 300倍 ぐらいの労働なんです
運動量なんです 私たちには手を挙げることは何のこともないんだけど
その病気になった人にとっては
ちょっとだけでも手を上げてみること
指を動かしてみることっていうのは
これ想像を絶する苦しい大変なことなんです
だからそこまででも苦労して苦労して泣きながらでも
ま とにかくまあ立ち上がると
まあ考えてみればありがたい立派な話で
だからそういうふうに人間っていうのはチャレンジはする
だから私は聞きたいのは
そうやって脳出血で倒れた人が
3年間毎日続けて苦労して苦労してリハビリやって歩けるようになりました
喋られるようになりましたと
じゃあ迷路から脱出したんですか？生きる問題から
その方がこの私たちにも勇気付けられるぐらいすごい人ですよと
こうもう脳出血で倒れたのに
やっぱりもう立ち上がってきましたと
治療も何もないのに いろんなこのリハビリをして
時々もう癌にしたってもね
まあもうダメですよと言われたら
それはあなたにダメだと言わせませんよと言って
しっかりと自分で頑張って
いろんなもう健康方法や治療方法
食事療法とかいろんなことをして
癌が消えちゃったとかね
克服しましたというケースはあります
それで問題は じゃあその人は人生の迷路から脱出してるんですかね
結局同じことでしょうに
例えば私に今日は癌がない
それで 1週間経って病院に行ったところで
あんた癌ですよと 悪性でかなり早く成長しているんだよと
その調子で計算してみると
まあ5年ぐらいかなと
それで私が腹が立って
あなたにそんなこと言わせませんよと言って
まあいろんな苦労して苦労して
もう癌を克服する それは何を得ているんですかね
元の状態に戻ったようなことでしょう
本当は戻ってないんですけどね
癌克服したんだからといって
若い時の体調に健康に戻ったわけじゃないんです
脳出血で倒れた人はもう歩けないと
もう一生そんなものだと言われて
もうそれには気が済まないんだから
頑張って歩けるようにしましたと
すべりなくウォーカーというなんとか器具もなく歩けるんだと
それで何か得ていますかね
だから何でしょうかね
ですから この私たちは不思議なこと
この頑張る人々を応援するんです
それぐらいのことに負けるなよと
私も同じことしてます
なんかくだらんことで悩んでるともう怒るんでね
アホではないかと そんなことでも来るなよと
もっともっと大きな問題があったら言ってくださいと
まあそう言われちゃうと
向こうも腹が立ちますね
自分にとっては大事な
すごい苦しみ悩みなのに
言われたらもう馬鹿にされちゃったんだと
もう腹が立つのはいいんだけど
それでも立ち上がっちゃうんですね
もう恥ずかしくなっちゃって
まあやっぱりなんとか自分で解決しますよと
そういうふうに私さえもいろんな生きる上で苦しみが出てきたら
まあそこはもう もう頑張りなさい
それぐらいのことで負けるなよという一言葉を言う
それだけじゃなくて 世の中では本当に頑張る人々がいて
まあそうやってももう無理だ
ダメだと言われても 自分で頑張って克服する
その苦しみを お釈迦様が聞くのは
それであなたは何を得ているんですかと
だから山を登ったような感じで
ものすごい苦労し ひどかったと
もう滑り滑り落ちましたと
ちょっと足が滑って ほんのちょっとのことで
もうもう死ぬかもしれませんでしたとかね
そこであのロープでも
あのもう何もつけるところもなかったところもありましたと
それでも私は山を登ってみたんだと
だから 登ってからよう降りたんです
それで得たものなんですかね
だからもう純単なる山登りなんです
それでそれぐらい命かけてあんた山が登りましたね
すごいですね と言われても
ですから 別にそれでなんでしょうかね
その世界なんでお釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
だから初めからお釈迦様がすごく違う次元で語っているんです
奥さんと喧嘩するのは苦しみだよということは
お釈迦様に関係ない次元なんです
そこはもう夫婦で何とかしなさいよと
それぐらいのことで あるいはものすごい
もう徹底的なわがままな女性と結婚したんだと
人の話は全く聞かない
もうもう暴れ馬そのものだと
それでも自分がいろいろ工夫して
克服して 普通のまともな人間に今なっているんだよと
それぐらいのことですから
そんな苦しみをお釈迦様が語っているわけじゃないんです
それは自分で何とかできます
買っていた牛が まあ昔の話なんですけどね
自分の田んぼを耕すために買っていた牛が
まあ檻を破って山に入っちゃったと
まあ田んぼはできない
苦しいでしょうね 食べて食べられる
食べられない 家族を養わない
子供には食べるものは作れないと
じゃあ山に入って牛を探せばいいでしょうに
それで山に入って調べてみると
やっぱり牛は虎にやられているんですね
ああ 大変だ もう終わりと
それでもその人に行く当てがないんでしょうかね
でも何とかすればいいですよ
それでも 何とかすればいい
自分の田んぼはできないんだったら
人の田んぼの仕事をお手伝いでもすれば
それからそれでも何か収入を得られるでしょうに
だから そういう人生の苦しみには
それなりの答えっていうのは
その場でその場であるんです
そんなどうったことはないんです
克服しようとしなかろうが
私はどっちでもいいと
例えばもう足が使えないんだと
使えないんだったら まあリハビリやって足を使えるようにするか
あるいはそんないらん足だからね
切断しちゃいしょうが
どちらでも同じことでしょうに
リハビリして使えるようになったっても
別にまあただ歩けるだけの結果で
足を切断して義足使ったってもと同じことで歩けると
だから何かもうもう単純で答えがあるんです
ですから 本当はこの人間が思っている人生の苦しみっていうのは
もうあまりにも単純すぎて
それに悩んでいることはすごい面白いんです
子供が言うことを聞かないんだ
もう生きていたって意味がないんだとかね
あるいはもう旦那が不倫して家出しました
それで子供一人 もうもうみんな出て行っちゃったんだと
私の人生 一体何なのかとかね
悩んだりするでしょ あんなものもバカもいいところで
どうったことない そんなことで
それこそ人生不幸だ 苦しいって
そういうことじゃないんですね
いたっても大したことはないし
旦那と子供が一緒にいたまま出て行ったっても
大したことはないし また戻ってきたっても
だから何でしょうかねと
そういうことから考えちゃうと
やっぱりお釈迦様がもうちょっと違う次元のことをおっしゃってるはずなんですね
ですから 迷路で考えてみる
迷路というものがありまして
どこへ行っても壁にぶつかる
本当は出口はない もし全く出口のない迷路だったら
もう 途中で疲れて死ぬでしょ
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
人間の生き方 生命の生き方っていうのは
出口のない迷路の中で
すごく勇気を持って頑張ってはいます
それは別にもう大丈夫でしょうしね
勇気を持って頑張っています
でもみんな出口ないんだからね
途中で死ぬんです それで面白いことに
じゃあ迷路に入れちゃった
周り見たらもうなんかもうここ行ってもなんか壁がある
行ってもなんか壁がある
まあいいや いいや 私はどこにも行かない
座っているぞと 一人が全然探検しないで座っている
もう一人はそんな怠け者でね
何かしら探しましょうよと行って必死になって探す
結果として人も死ぬ 出口がないんだから
だから まあどういう評価をすればいいんですかね
まあ何もしないで黙って怠けているよりは頑張った方がいいんじゃないかなということも言えないわけでもないんだけど
だからって何も得てないんだからね
だから逆に考えて その人は疲れて疲れて死んじゃったし
この人は何もしないでごろ寝していて死んじゃったし
そうすると何もしなかった人の方が儲かったんじゃないかなと
とも思われるし やっぱり怠けないでとにかくチャレンジしたんだ
探検しましたと 努力しました
すごいというふうにも言えるし
だから人生においても
ただもうまあもう怠けてね
何もしないで もうただこつこつなんとかして生きていて
それほど光もなくて そこら辺のサラリーマンで
まあそこそこの給料で
まあそこそこそこら辺にいる誰かと結婚して
まあそこそこの子供一人二人ぐらい作って
それで年取って死んでしまう
誰も知らない それで子供たちにももう聞いたら
あなたの弟 いつ亡くなったっけねというぐらいのことで
子供たちに忘れられているとかね
そういう人々もいますよ
みんなに悪口を言われるんだから
葬式だけはするんだけど
もうそれから法事なんかはね
忘れている そういうふうな人もいるし
まあ写真貼ったり 銅像を作ったり
国民にスケールで 国民でもう何といいますか
この人が亡くなったことを悩んだり
悲しがったりしてね そういう人々もいる
日本人でもないのに 外国の他のどこかの人なのに
死んだことでこちらで泣く人もいる
すごい人だと そういう人物もいるでしょ
で 死んでももう１５０0年か
もう１６００年経ってるかもしれませんだけど
聞いたらすぐみんな死んだ日にちわかってます
どこでどんな戦いでこの人が亡くなったかとかね
自分の父親はいつでしたっけ？とわからないと
ナポレオンだ ナポレオンは何年
何年とかどうか どんなああいう場所で死にましたよと
というふうな人生も世の中でありますね
ろくに勉強はしない 真面目に仕事もしない
もう家族のことももう全然もう気にしない
ただご飯食べて まあご飯作ってもらったら
それ食べてそのままごろ寝したりとか
そういう まあ我々からいればもうだらしない
もうすごいもうつまらない人生の人もそうではなくて
お金一文もなくても それでも頑張って億万長者になって
日本全国もう会社作るんじゃなくて
世界的に至るところでもうなんとか株式会社やなんとかとか作って
世界一流の億万長者になって死ぬ人もいるでしょうし
だからお釈迦様は聞くのは
その二人とも何を得て死にますかと
一日ちょっとバイトをして食べている人もいます
それで あの あの人 誰でしたっけ？コンピューターの人がビル・ゲイツがいるんですね
世界一金持ちで どちらの方が立派ですかね
あるいはホームレスの人がいて
ちょっと何か食べるものでもないんでしょうか
そこら辺何かもらって
まあ賞味期限切れた弁当でもいただいて
それを食べて それで寝る
ただ また片側にビル・ゲイツさんがいる
私が聞きたいのは ビル・ゲイツさんにあなたの人生はダメですよと言えますかと
ホームレスの人に 言えないんです
結局二人とも同じだから
何も得ることなく死んじゃうんです
だから それ評価次第で
ビル・ゲイツさんが学生の時からも
もうじっとしていられなくて頑張りました
で 会社作って世界一金持ちになりました
まだ大学を卒業してないと
だからすごいんじゃないかと
と評価もできます 逆に何やってるんでしょうね
お金あったって あなたには結局
昼ご飯 2回食べることもできないし
ズボン 4着いっぺんに着ることも着ることもできないし
でお金あるんだからって
自分のコートにあのもう 1 ミリ単位でダイヤいっぱいもうつけて着ることもできないしね
気持ち悪いでしょうに
そんなことしたっても
別に誰も面白がらないしね
そこで彼がもう世界で一番高い美術品やらね
もうボンボン買ってるんだと言ったっても
だからどこかの美術館みたいなものをそこでそこで置いているだけでしょうに
だから ある美術館にあった美術品がこの美術館に引っ越しただけのことで
その引っ越しのために 4 5億円かかりましたと
距離としてはもしかするとまあまあ 40 キロぐらい距離とかね
実はそういうことでしょう
彼もいろんなものを集めていますけどね
だからこのすごい高価な美術品とか競りに出しちゃいますね
あるある屋敷にある品物が競りに出して
これは 4 5億円ですよ
はい 買ったぞという その人はそれを持って自分の部屋に
この部屋からあの部屋に移動する
二人とも死ぬんですね
結局 あの品物を置いておいて
だからそんなバカバカらしいことを何もしないで
あの道路の階段の下にしゃがみ込んでいる人は
なんかお腹がすいた そこら辺ちょっと何かもらいましょうと言って食べてきて
またしゃがんでこうやってごろ寝していると
だから本当は誰の評価は難しいんです
あんたただ座っているだけで
私はこの美術品 こちらからここまで引っ越しましたよと
どうやって言われるんですかね
どれぐらい？これ まあこれはもうかなりきつかったと
競争も激しかった もうまあやっぱり億も値段も値札は付いてんだよと
その億円値札を払うために
その人どれぐらい苦労しますかね
そこでホームレスの人からあんたもともとあの絵をね
運ばなかった方がよかったでしょ
楽で 絵の引っ越しにそれぐらいお金かかるんだったらね
名義変更に  そういうことで
この世の中ではみんな人生には人生は努力するべき
努力するべきです 言うんだけど
答えなんですかね やっぱり虚しいでしょ
よくよく見ると何か無意味なんですね
美術品は引っ越しする
例えばアメリカにある誰かの絵とかね
日本で人気ある画家っていうのは何人か決まってますね
護法やらね なんとかって
なんでしたっけ で そういう何人かがいてね
その人のこれぐらいの絵をね
アメリカから飛行機で日本まで運ぶと
まあ億円だと 別に運ばなきゃいいでしょうし
それで億円払うということには
もうかなり苦労しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
そういう人生なんですね
ですから ドッカっていうのは
本当は苦しいっていう意味じゃなくて
虚しいという意味なんです
そこがお釈迦様のこの違うところなんです
私たちは虚しいと思ってないんです
有義だと で よくよくよくよく考えちゃうと
何やっているんでしょうかと
あなたは？と聞きたくなります
あのフンゴロガシって虫がいるんですね
生まれた時から一生懸命苦労して
もうもうフンをね まあ大体この動物のフンですけどね
あの牛やら馬やらね それを集めて集めて
丸めて丸めて丸めて まあそれでもう死んじゃうんですね
とにかく終わってから
で フンゴロガシに聞いたらね
あんたは生まれてきて何をなさいましたかと
これからあなたのあれ
何て言いますか 歴史書きますからと
本を出版しますからと
私はまあ大きなフンをね
フンを玉を作りましたと
そこで同じ人が人間にインタビューしたっても同じことですよね
私はまああの会社を私が作ったんだと
今は歳だから もうもう引退
別にそれ仕事もないでしょうに
だから同じことなんですね
あのモハメド・アリにあなたは人生で何を得たんだい？私はもうボクシングチャンピオンで
世界チャンピオンで これこれぐらいトロフィーを持っているんだと
はい わかりました じゃあこちらサインしてくださいと
サインできません もう手足動かないんです
病気ですからね だからわからない
モハメド・アリさんがワールドチャンピオンになったこと
悪いかと 悪いとは言いにくいし
頑張ったし だから だからといって
その人は何を得ているんでしょうかというと
人生に対し 人生というものに対しては何も得ていないんです
今は激しい あのあれ あのパーキンソンという病気でね
まあ手も足も動かなくて
こうやって震えながら歩けも歩けないし
車椅子で で あの 前の大統領
誰でしたっけ？あの ん？今病気になっている人
あの うん そうそう レーガン
このレーガンさんにしたってもね
堂々と光り輝いて大統領としていて
今おそらく自分の名前はわからないという状態になって亡くなる
だから亡くなる瞬間で
レーガンさんに大統領でいたこと
世界で一番強い政治家にリーダーになったことは
どんなふうにプラスになりますかね
遺体の周りの偉い人々は集まるでしょうね
亡くなったらそれぐらいでしょう
それ別に ですから このちょっと残酷に人生を見なくちゃいけないんです
きつく見てみると まあどっちでも同じやと
だから私は言いたいのは
ミミズいますね だからミミズが土の中に入って
もう動いて動いて動いて
ちょっと外穴を掘って
それから腐ってかけてる葉っぱ一つ引っ張ってもらって
それを食べて またちょっと先に進んで
また一つ食べて先に進んでとか
そこで途中で亡くなっちゃうでしょうに
それと偉大なる人 名前を言うのは失礼になりますから避けますけど
そうやって世界征服しましたというふうな偉大なる人の人生って
どこらへん何が違いますかね
何か形跡残しちゃうんですけど
ミミズも素晴らしい形跡を残して亡くなるでしょうに
土の中であっちこっち穴を掘って
それで葉っぱ食べては出す
食べては出すと それで土が生きているんですね
それで植物はものすごい立派に
それぐらいのことを偉大な人間にできますかね
世界征服している人々にできますかね
よく考えると ミミズぐらいの仕事もできないんじゃないですかね
ですから この人生に 人生楽しいか苦しいかという問題じゃないんです
人生そのものが どう頑張っても
どう努力しても どう踏ん張っても
やがてはい バイバイ さようならと
ご褒美なしに終わっちゃうんです
あんただけ特別だよっていうこと
誰にもないんです その意味なんですね
ドッカというのは だからお腹が痛くて
痛くて苦しいとかね そんなもんじゃないんです
地震で家が潰れちゃったんだから
もうすごい悲しいんだと
なぜそういうものは苦しみではないと言えますかというと
地震が起きて家が潰れて
人生は苦しいわけじゃなくて
その被害者だけ苦しいんであって
それはもう全宇宙的な真理じゃないでしょうね
洪水で流されて死んで
やっぱり苦しい そんなことお釈迦様はおっしゃりません
なぜならばという洪水で家を流されて人が死ぬということは
これ稀なケースでしょうに
みんなにあることじゃないでしょうに
だからこの地震は起きるわ
火山噴火してもう村やら町一人丸ごともう灰でつぶされるわっていうのはどうったことない
そんなことはどこでもみんなに起こる出来事じゃないんだから
例えば人間 なんとかもうがんになりましたとかね
事故を起こして 子供でも親でも誰でも死んだったとかね
そういうのはもう全ての人類にある問題じゃないしね
誰かはもうたまたまそういう不幸に出会うだけで
仕事をクビになることも
仕事をちょっときつくなることも
もう会社でちょっといじめられているんだっていうぐらいのことっていうのは
これはもう万人の真理
人類の真理というわけじゃないんです
ちょっと何かすればそれは解決できます
ですから 私たち考えている苦しみもお釈迦様にとっては全然考えてもないんです
ですから 私たち考えた人生は幸せだということも
そのレベルなんです 赤ちゃんが笑っちゃったとか
それですごい幸せ感じるでしょ
そんなレベルなんです
で 奥さんと例えばもう 1年ずっと喧嘩ばっかりしていたんだと
そこで自分がそこら辺で安売り売っているところで
まあ６万ぐらいの指輪を買ってきて
普通の値段だったらもしかすると 1万5000円ぐらいかもしれません
指輪買ってきて もう喧嘩ばっかりだから
あなたにプレゼント買ってきますよというのも恥ずかしいし
言えないし まあそこら辺にちょっと置いて帰ると
そしたら奥さんがそれを見て
もうなんかすごく喜ぶ
喜ぶんで一言葉で見たら
やっぱりあなたっていうのは本当にいい人ですねとか
一言言われたら それだけで
あの男の人の今までのあった苦しみも全部消えちゃって
まあ幸福なこと そこら辺で私なんか仏教の語る人だったら殺されるかもしれない
お前らダメやと こんなに人生幸せなのに
ですから人間語っている幸せも大体そんな程度のものなんです
親に逆らって 親に迷惑は一生かけてわがまま放題で
もう大きくなった子供でも
いくらか一人前になってきてくるところで
あのわがままなくなっちゃいますからね
やっぱり世界一でお母さんお父さんというのはやっぱり世界一ですねと一言葉だけ言っておけば
それで一生大丈夫です
あの両親は一生 自分の子供というのは最高だと思ってくれるんです
それから別に面倒を見てあげなくても
何でもいいんです まあそれぐらい単純でしょ
皆さんはそうでしょう
結局は それぐらい一言葉言ってくれればね
だからこの人間を思っている幸せも
大したことはない 人間いう苦しみも大したことはない
逆に考えてみてください
奥さんが旦那をよく褒めるんだと
ちょっとしたことでもなんとかたっても
もう例えばもうだからあなたと結婚したんだよと言われると
旦那さんはすごくなんか踏ん張っちゃって
褒めてくれたんだからね
まあ今日はちょっとボーナスがね
去年よりはちょっと 2万円多いですよと言ったら
だから私はあなたと結婚したんだから
というと なんかすごく別に何も理屈ないんだけどね
それで男としてはすごく喜んじゃうんですね
自分を認めてくれたんだから
褒めてくれたんだから
それで考えてみてください
25 年間そうやって旦那さんは褒められっぱなしで
大げさな褒めではなくて
ほんのちょっとの褒めなんですけど
そこで奥さん 2人がおばあさんになったところでしゃべっていると
あんたよく旦那さん あいつはバカだからね
おばさん二人でせんべい食べながら喋っていることだからね
であんたはね なんかうちは旦那とよく喧嘩するんだけど
あなたはやっぱり変わって喧嘩もないしね
よく褒めるもんですねとかね
まあうちのやつはね バカだから
それ一言葉言ったとします
それで自分の耳に入ったとします
あの 40 年間の褒めはどうなるんでしょう
その場合は  40 年間のあの舞い上がり
あの地震 それぐらいもろい幸せなんです
苦しみも同じくね ものすごいもうもろいもんなんです
大したことじゃないんです
人が病気になっただけで
ものすごくもう真剣になって泣いたり笑ったりする
もしその人死んじゃったりするでしょうに
もう納得できなくて 我慢できなくて
まあ最長１か３ヶ月間ぐらい経つと
もうじりじりじりじりと忘れてしまうでしょうに
うん  そこがお釈迦様が
だからあんまりそういうそこはまあ喋ってないんで
ほんと言ってますよ こんなつまらないんだと
あなた方の幸せなんかは何なのかと
あんた方言ってる不幸も何なのか
そんなぐらいのことって
なんかちょっとしたシャボン玉のようなものでしょうと
あ 綺麗と思った瞬間もう弾けているんだから
それで人生というそのもの
いわゆる人生ではなくて
生きているということ
だからミミズにしたっても
生まれて死ぬまで生きているんだから
そのセットを全部考えてみると
すべての生命を考えてみると
そんなもんですかと だから自分の人生に点数を入れてみると
正直にプラスもマイナスもあって
全部総合計算してみると0になっちゃうんですから
だから人生ね 幸福もあって不幸もあったり
だからプラス入れてマイナス入れて
プラス入れてマイナス入れて
全部私の人生の総合点数はあらゼロですと
そこが誰が点数入れたっても同じことなんです
本当は0っていうのはすごいことなんです
なかなか0にならないんです
ほとんどマイナスなんですけどね
これ まれな珍しい人がね
人生計算してみると あの0になりましたと
といえば それがすごいことですけど
でも皆様方 0ですということにも笑っちゃったんだからね
本当は0になるのももう
何千万人に一人ぐらいの人間なんです
大体我々は1年間苦労して1時間楽しむというぐらいの割り当てなんです
だからマイナスで まあそれはどうでもいいんですけど
やっぱり結局すべての生命ってそういうことだと
宗教の世界では それはまあ多かれ少なかれ
もしかするとそんなもんではないかという気持ちもあるんです
人生は だから天国に行こうではないかと
JR のコマーシャルがありますね
京都へ行こうと  そんな風なコマーシャルを出すんですね
だから天国に行こうではないかと
だから天国に行ったらこういう人生でないということはどうやってわかるんですかね
そういうことで お釈迦様が生きているという
そのものが何なのかと研究してみたんですね
それでお釈迦様はまた普遍的な定義を見つけて
その定義は神々にも誰にでも当てはまる
で 天国の話を聞いてみてください
別にどんな宗教の話でもいいんです
天国の話 阿弥陀様の極楽堂の話
皆様方 天国のこと知らないんだったらね
まあ同じ似てる話でしょ
その話を聞いてみてください
そちらにいる人々も結局我々と同じでしょうに
例えば天国に行ったら何一つも見えませんよと言ってみてください
書いてみてください 誰も行きたがらないでしょうに
天国に行ったらかすかな音でも聞こえませんと
これから皆様方に天国のお話をしてあげます
この天国ということは大変素晴らしいところで
まるっきり何一つも見えません
そちらはまるっきり何一つも聞こえません
その世界でまるっきり何一つも味わうこともできませんと
その天国でまるっきり何も感じることもできませんと言ったら
誰も誰が行きたいんですかね
誰も行きたがらないんです
だから天国のストーリーを書く方々は
天国では見たい放題 美しいものを見えると
遊びたい放題遊べると
耳にはものすごい美しい音楽しか触れませんと
口には最高のおいしい味しか触れませんということしか書いてないんです
で まあそういうのはまあ神話物語なんですが
実際にお釈迦様は天界と超次元のね
生命との話し合ったり
見ていくことがよくありましたからね
みんなくだらなくて同じなんです
低次元の神々と喋った
こういう質問された こういうふうに答えたとかありますよ
大したことないんです
人間よりはちょっと鋭いことを聞いたりはするんだけど
まあそれでもお釈迦様から見ればそんな程度ですかと
あるお坊さんがすごい若い人なんです
昔 今じゃないんだ お釈迦様の時代で
すごいもうピンピン元気な若い人でね
森の中で一人でずっと瞑想してるんですね
そのお坊さんのことを何か気に入った神がいたんです
まあ心霊ですけどね 心配するんですね
こんな元気な若い子がね
かわいそうに 森の中で一人で修行ばっかりしやがったって
心配しちゃったんです
心配して この若者に見えるように来たんです
来て 君がね 目の前にいっぱい楽しみがあるのに
人生はね なんで遠い将来の幸福のために頑張るんですかと
だから修行することはいくらか分かってるんで
修行するということは
もう遠い遠い将来 やがてなんとかいいことあるでしょという将来的な計画なんですね
でも こんなかわいくて
すごい元気な美男で 若くて
こんな男の子がね 森の中で一人で頑張るよりは
目の前の楽しみを味わった方がいいんじゃないかと
みんなとも遊んだりね
まあもう若い女の子でも見つけて結婚したりとかね
だから目の前の幸せをね
置いておいて 遠い未来の幸福を目指して
あんたね なんか悲しい
かわいそうと言ったら
若この若いお坊さんは
なんかこいつは言ってることなんかおかしいんじゃないかと思って
この人なんかおかしいこと
だからあまり勉強してないんですよ
仏教は 修行するんだけど
ちょっと待ってください
お釈迦様の教えから見れば
私たちはこの目の前の幸福を捨てて
将来の楽しみを得るために頑張っているわけじゃないんだと
お釈迦様の話から見ると
我々こそ目の前で幸せをつかもうとしているんじゃないかなと思いますよと言っても
それはあんたどういう意味ですかと
どういう意味ですかと聞いても
私はわかりませんと だと思いますよと
困ったんですね 向こうの人と
この心霊が ったら神 それで若者も
それあなた説明してくださいと言われたら
若者は私にはできません
一応なんかそんな感じの話をお釈迦様がしているんだと
遠い遠い将来で幸せになるために今は苦労しているのではないんだと
君たちが 君たちが今すぐ
今の瞬間で幸せになるために修行しているんだと
仏教は今すぐ結果を得られる教えだよと
明日ではないんだと という話は聞いたことがあるんだと
意味はわかりません だから神霊に言ったんですね
あんたね 自分で聞いてみたらどうですかね
私に邪魔をしないで 私はお釈迦様に会えないんだと
もう修行中だから あんたは行ってきなさいと
言ったら 神霊はこうお願いするんですね
と言っても 我々は霊の世界でね
お釈迦様に近寄れないんだと
そちらはものすごい巨大なパワー
力のある神々やら霊 神霊たちやら集めているんだから
我々はものすごく遠く遠くも近寄れないんだと
でもあんた方同じ人間でしょ？だからもう羨ましくてたまらないんですよ
だから自分にはお釈迦様に聞こえるんだと
だから聞いてくださいと
あんたその質問をすると
私もあなたと一緒に行って聞きます
説法聞きます 聞きますよと言って
はい わかりましたと そのお坊さんが修行
その時期終わったら お釈迦様に挨拶して
お釈迦様にこういうほんのちょっとおかしいことがあったんだけど
村の中で私は一人ですけどね
なんか変な姿の形の人が来て
私をからかっちゃったんだと
私もからかいは返せはしましたけどね
でも結局説明できなかったんだと
それでその神がお釈迦様に説明聞いてくださいと頼んだんですけど
結局私もわからないんだからね
お釈迦様はできれば説明してくださいと
もしかすると その変な霊もそこら辺で今いると思いますよと
言ったら その霊もやっぱりいたんで
いて その後ろにいて耳に言ったんで
もう聞きなさいよ 比丘よ
釈迦尊に聞きなさい 私が聞いているんだからと
言ったら お釈迦様は その若者は問題はないんだから
この神霊にやっぱり答えたんですね
でもその答えはすごい ４
行の経典ですごい難しいんですよ
もう私にしても 二 三時間かかります
解説解釈する 説するために
いわゆるこのインファリブル
この言葉で表れない世界について
いわゆる表現しにくい
表現に成り立たない世界についてという話でね
言ったら その神が全然わかりませんと
言ったら またお釈迦様は他の芸を教えたんですね
でも難しすぎてわかりませんと
それでまたもっと柔らかいこと
それでもわからないんですね
最後にもうしょうがないということで
お釈迦様はね やっぱり生きている間はね
悪いことをやめなさい
生きているようで悪いことをやめなさい
いいことをしなさい 心を汚すなよと
はい 終わりと まあそれぐらいだったらわかりますよと
その神霊が喜んで帰りましたけど
ですから この中国の ですね
ある中国のお坊さんにね
まあある偉い人があって
あなた方の仏教は何をおっしゃっているんですか？と言ったら
この悪いことをするなかれ
善いことをしなさい 心を育てなさい
それが私たちの教えやと言ったら
その偉い人が なんだ ガキにも言えることではないかと
そしたらそのお坊さんが
まあそれはその通りです
でも世の中で一番一番頭のいい知識人でも実践はできないんだと
と言って言い返しましたそうで
それは中国の話でね だからまあお釈迦様も悪いことをするなかれというだけでね
単純だ 単純だと思ったらね
それはちょっと違うし
その話も言ったのは やっぱりこの人間が思っている幸せっていうのはね
まあそれほど大したことじゃない
とにかく神々の話から入りましたから
神々の世界にしたっても
我々知っている我々の伝説
物語にある神々っていうのは
人間とほとんど同じで
お釈迦様に出会った神々にしたっていうのも
それほど大したものではないんですね
他の宗教で出てくる神々よりは
まあ立派に頭は動くんですけどね
立派なことを考えてはしたんだけど
やっぱりそれでもまあそれほど生命としては生命であって
ですから 結局は生きていて
年取って亡くなりました
ご苦労様です それしか言えないんです
誰の人生についても ミミズの人生についても
フンコロガシの人生についても
ゾウさんの人生についても
世界のすべて素晴らしい人間の人生についても
天界の神々の人生についてはご苦労様でしたと
その価値 その意味がお釈迦様は生はドゥッカであると
生きることはドゥッカであるとおっしゃったので
虚しいという意味なんです
それ微かにでも知っておけば
すごく楽になるんです
ただ 日常生活の中いろいろ問題あるでしょうに
大体人間というのは それだけに精一杯命までかけるでしょうに
そこまでかける必要あります？単純単純で
学校の問題であるか 教育の問題であろうか
政治的な経済的な問題であるか
夫婦の間の問題であろうか
もうあまりにも単純で
そんな命かける必要はないんでしょうに
なんでこれ一生命かけるかというと
この人生虚しいと思ってないんだからなんですね
どうせ最後は虚しいんだからとわかっちゃえばもう楽なんです
なんで私だけ不幸ですよと
例えばガンだよと言われた
言われるでしょうし そうするとなんで私に？といきなり聞くでしょうに
あれが不幸中不幸なんです
ガンにかかってもかからなくても同じですから
結局は どうせ何も得るものなく死んでしまっちゃうんです
手ぶらで そんなにヒステリーになって
神経質になって苦しむ必要はないのです
だから人生は全部 まあそういう
まあもうということだとわかったら
会社に行ったところで
会社の社長でも係長でもいいんですけど
自分を読んで まああんた明日から仕事に来なくてもよろしいですよと
一応３ヶ月とか あるいは１年分ぐらいの給料は後で会社で振り込みますからと ３
ヶ月とか分言われたら
それだけで自殺したくなるでしょうね
でも 人生は神々であろうか
全部まとめてどう見たっても
迷路の中でぐるぐるやっていることだから
ああそう はい わかります
それで終わっちゃうんです
じゃあ早くお金を送ってねと
明日から他のことをやればいいでしょうし
だからこのあまりにも楽になるんです
生きることは あまりにも楽になるんです
何があっても この世の中でみんな神経質で
もうお互いに競争して戦って
牙を出して もう負けてたまりません
たまりませんとかね もうやり合っちゃったりしていて
ではすべてどう見てもこんな意味だよとわかっている人は
こうやって手をもう足を手を組んで見ているんです
これは並の楽しみじゃないんです
その楽ということが だから苦を知りなさいと
ドッカを知りなさいと
それからもう一つドッカがありまして
この私たちにとっては
このもう本当は認めてなくないんだけど
すごい苦しみ ストレスがあるんです
誰にでも生きてるんだったら
それは何でしょうかというと
私たちはこの生きることには価値を入れてますね
命は尊い 当たり前と思ってるでしょうに
この尊い命 その一言葉が生きるものとしては悪魔の言葉なんです
仏教ははっきりと悪魔の言葉だと言っているんです
悪魔の言葉 悪魔は来て
このように語りました
人間にとってはこの世の中で生きることこそ幸せな尊いことはなしと
それで それに添えて もう聖者はこういうふうに答えたと
この世において執着して生きることほど苦しみがありませんと
ですから あれが悪魔の言葉なんです
人生は尊いと 生きることは尊い
命が尊いと なぜかというと
尊いんだから自分にすごい価値が入れる
ですから 手段選ばず生きていなくちゃいけない
喧嘩してでも生きていなくちゃいけない
相手を殺してでも自分が生き延びなくてはいけないんですね
それはどれぐらい苦しいと思いますかね
だから不幸になったら
なんで私が不幸になったんですかと
月一回 100円神社にお布施しているのにとかね
だからいくらもう 1万回経典をあげても
何をしても もう そういう不幸になったら
みんななんで私がこうならなくてはいけないんですかと
なんで私がやることはもう失敗するんですか？とかね
とすごい苦しみを感じちゃうんですね
だから そのごく普通な成功であろうか
もう成功でなかろうか
ものすごくストレスを感じ
例えばすごく成功している人がいますね
会社とものすごいもう抜群にもう億万長者になってるんだと
すべてうまくいって そういう人にしても
やっぱり頑張らなくちゃ
新しいものをアイデアを作ってチャレンジしなくちゃ
これを潰れたらあかんと
ここまで成長させたんだからということでしょうに
お母さんも私にはもうご飯も食べる
食べさせることはできなくて
苦労してバイトばっかりして
夜私は一人で悲しく寝ていたんだよと
お母さんが仕事に行って
それでそういう私が今日本で一流の金持ちになっていて
お母さんもすごいと今喜んで楽しがっているんだよと
だからこの会社が この仕事
この商売 ずっと回らなくちゃあかんと苦しんでるんです
その人にも寝る暇も休みも何もなく
頑張らなくちゃいけないし
だから価値を入れると
そちらにすごい苦しみが出てくる
そこで祈り 尊い と思ったっても
面白いことにみんな死ぬんです
そこでみんな確実に死ぬにも関わらず
よくあんなことを言うんです
尊いと もし死ぬこと 死ぬものが尊いんだったら
もうカボチャも尊いし
落ち葉も尊いし もう何でも尊いでしょうに
そこで自分に価値入れちゃうと
死にたくはないという気持ちが生まれてくるんですね
それだけは嫌ですと こんな尊い命
死にたくはないと思った途端
また限りなく苦しみ ストレスがかかってくるんです
死にたくはなくても 死にたくたっても
どうでもいいことで死ぬんですから
放っておきなさいというのは私たちの考え方なんですね
それよりはもうまあ必ず死にますと
それは確認しておく まあ必ず消えますから
まあそこら辺でそこそこ生きてましょうということになるでしょうに
そんなに感情的に 嫉妬
憎しみ 苦しみ 競争心 で
なんで苦労するんですかね
生きている日にちは決まってるでしょうに
何日間あなたが生きているんですかと
だったら その決まってる日にちで人と仲良くして
楽しく気楽にいればいいでしょうに
死なないだろうということを仮定するんだから
1 年間苦労しても  1 年間喧嘩してもへっちゃらですよ
みんな時々 40 年間も恨み憎しみを持ち続ける
時々 60 年間  80 年間でも恨み憎しみを持ち続ける方々もいますでしょうに
だから ああいう人生はもう虚しいと言えるところじゃないんですね
虚しいの上で苦しみの塊なんです
ですから この価値入れる
人生に価値入れる 大事だと思う
それこそが悪魔の言葉になってしまって
人間にはいかなる苦しみも巣食ってくるんです
ですから 価値がないんだということでドゥッカと言うんです
価値がないんだということはごまかしではないんです
本当は価値がある でも
ちょっと我々騙されて
騙してお釈迦様が私たちを騙して価値がないと言っているということでもないんです
我々は子供騙しするでしょ
嘘を言って子供を落ち着いてもらうために
そういうふうにお釈迦様は子供騙し言ってるものじゃないんです
だからお釈迦様は堂々と言うんだ
自分が徹底的に研究したところで
修行してみたところで
あ 全ては無意味で価値がないんだよと発見しましたと
それでも悟っちゃうんです
あ なるほどと それで全部猿が猿ありますね
で 猿はこのザルと言うんですか？入れ物
ザル ザルありますね それはいくら大きくても
大きければ大きいほど
例えば川の中に入れておいてください
かなりの水はその中に入ってます
でも上に上がったら何一つもないんですね
軽々と そういうふうなことで
あ なるほど そんなものでしたと
本当は我々もバカでかい人生というザルを持っていて
それは川の中にあるんですけど
これは運ぶ運べそうもないんだ
こんな水重くて重くて冗談じゃないかと悩んでるだけで
もう取ってみてくださいと
何のこともない サラサラと水が落ちちゃって軽いと
だからこの人生生きるということは穴だらけやとわかった瞬間で
あの煩悩というものは全部お釈迦様の心から落ちてしまっちゃったんですね
だから私たちは余計な価値を入れているんだから
それも非論理的で よくよく見るとそれほど価値あるというわけじゃないんですね
で 大変苦しんでいます
ですから お釈迦様が苦しみをなくすために苦しみだよと言っているんです
で 苦しみも余計なことで
私たちのすべての苦しみは
愛別する苦であろうか
病気で苦しむことであろうか
年取って苦しいということでも
まあもうどうったことはないものなんですけど
でもそこに我々は足引っ張られて
手を引っ張られ 足かせ手かせでもう動けなくなっちゃって
もう嘆きわめいていますね
だから苦しみの上で苦しむ
気楽に空気のように動けなくなっちゃう
そこは一つのもう一つのドッカの意味なんですね
また意味があります あの
とにかくこの我々の注釈書でドッカっていうのは
この苦しいと訳してないんです
ドゥという分析するんですね
こういう風にドゥということとカということ
で ドゥの意味は そのその場合によって意味が変わりますけど
その場合はまあいわゆる無価値
大したことはないという
ことを言うためにこれ付けちゃいますと
日本で言えばなんて言いますかね
日本語で何か似ている言葉
ん？ん？ 日本語もあると思います
思い浮かびません 例えばこのまあ小屋という言葉がありますね
まあ小屋と言ったって豪邸じゃないんですね
あの小さいという漢字を入れただけで
だから この一つの漢字の前に小という小という字を入れちゃうと小屋と読んじゃうし
それで意味も同じでしょうに
まあまあ どうしたことはないと
例えば石と書けば なんかちょっとわからないんです
どんな程度の石かと それに小石と入れちゃうと
あるいは石ころにしちゃうと
子はさし さ 頭に入れるか
最後にもう平仮名でころと入れるか
どちらかでしょうに 石ころといえば誰も気にしないでしょう
でも石だけだったらちょっとわからないんですね
どんな程度ものかと 川の前に小入れたらどうなりますか？小川でしょ
そうすると別に小川 そういう感じで
このあの そんな大したことないということの意味のものなんです
別に小という漢字書いたっても
それは小さいという意味ではないんです
漢字にもいろいろ意味がありますからね
だからその場合に意味が
まあ小さいという意味でも使います
まあ小屋って言えば まあまあ小さいという意味でも使いますが
やっぱり価値としても別にそれほど豪邸ではないという意味でもあります
そういう風に  名詞の前にほんのちょっと一言葉使えるだけ付けるだけで
あるいは名詞の後ろにほんのちょっと付けるだけ
意味はない まあそんなもん
そんな大事に考えるものではないんだよと
ですから そこはそうやって
この 無価値 非価値という意味でドゥ使いません
カっていうのは まあ空にカというでしょうと
空という意味なんです
空はどういう風に言いますか？空でしょ
ですから 意味もないだけではなくて
それさらに大したことはないと
それでドッカですよと
いわゆる空しいということなんです
単純な日本語で言えば
カはあの意味は空 いわゆる空ですね
で 空と言った途端 実体はない
もうもうもう空しいということになりますけど
それさらにどうも入れちゃう
と これ大空空とか大乗仏教ですごい価値入れてますけど
そんな価値も入れてないんです
だからドッカっていうのは
まあただまあ無意味 まあどうったことはない
気にするほどではないと
だから一切は空であるということは
一切はそんな気にするほどのものじゃないということなんです
そんなに気にするほどですかと
そこで修行してみなさいと
そんなにも気にするほどのことを見つかるんでしょうかと
何も見つからないはずだ
同時に分かればわかるほど
なんか心が喜び 安らぎ
気楽になってきます えーと
まあそこら辺くらいでは十分だと思いますが
今日はいっぱい まあ今日持ってきた情報ひとつも言ってないんです
うん  これからできるだけ早く打ちて
この残っている意味を説明していきます
あの そこはね この世の中で
この私たちは 私は日本語でこの現象という言葉をよく使うんです
現象 現象と 仏教の言葉はサンカーラなんです
複数形でサンカーラと言うんです
で 古い仏教用語で それ行という漢字が入れます
行 行くという感じ 銀行の行という漢字があります
それはそれはもう古い日本語の訳ですけどね
でも行といってもわからないし
だから私は現象という言葉を使っています
そこでお釈迦様が一切の現象は空であるとおっしゃったんです
一切は空であると言ってはあまりないんです
別に一切と言ったってわからないしね
一切の現象は空であると
この現象って何でしょうかね
現象っていうのは  成り立っているすべてのものに言えるもので
ここら辺は説明どうしよう
コンディショナル すべてもう成り立っているもの
組み立てられているものという意味なんです
例えばこちらで水入ってるペットボトルありますよ
と思っても これが現象で
なぜ現象かというと やっぱりこのあるエチレンのポリエチレンのものがある
ある形にとらなくににならなくちゃいけないし
中に水が入ってなきゃいけないし
そこでこれに我々は蓋というかもしれません
なぜ蓋というと ある働きをして
こちらでこうやってあるんだから
ですから組み立てたんだから
その現象が成り立つ これにマイクロフォンというでしょ
これはなぜマイクロフォンというかというと
いろんなプラスチックの部品
金属の部品 プラスチックの部品と金属の部品が適当に組み合わせた上でマイクロフォンと言うんです
だからマイクロフォンというのは現象です
マイクロフォンには心臓
魂 何かあるわけじゃないんです
ただ組み立てたんだから
一時的にそうなっただけ
で そこが古い経典では
この車というたとえで説明するんですね
車ありますよと ありますよと
じゃあどちらが車ですか？と
車輪 軸 あるいはくびき
あるいは屋根 あるいは飾り
どちらが車ですか？と
どちらも車ではありません
だから例えば ABCDEFGとかね
10種類ぐらいの部品がある
車にも一つも車ではないのに
不思議なこと 組み立てたら車があるんだよと言うんですね
そこが現象論なんですね
もともとは全くなかったんです
ただ 組み立てたら一時的に存在するようになっちゃうんです
逆に見ても 車の車輪は永久的に車輪でしょうに
つなげただけで車輪が変身して違う品物になったわけでもないでしょうに
例えばこの服ありますね
服と言うんだけど 結局糸でしょ？糸は今も糸でしょうに
だから糸と服の関係は何なんでしょうかね
伊藤にもともと服があったんですかね
伊藤一本見たら あ こういう風なかっこいい服だなとかね
なかったでしょうに でも
伊藤はそうやってつなげてみたところ
ああ 結構いい生地だなとかなるでしょうに
そこで 服のね まあ縦軸の糸を我々は別々にしてもらう
それで何か消えますか？何か大事なもの落ちますか？どこかに
あ 生地が落ちちゃったんだとか調べてみてください
何も落ちません もし生地という実体があったならば
あの糸をどんどんどんどんバラしていくと
生地が幽霊のような感じで生地として逃げてるかもしれませんですけど
そんなこともないでしょうに
ですから この現象という言葉
サンカーラという言葉は仏教のもう命なんです
組み立ててないものは何一つもないんです
例えばこちら 部屋があります
っても まあただもうコンクリートやらいろんなものをコンクリートだから
もういろいろ部品をもうそこら辺もそれそれなりに組み立てただけ
それで今すごい立派な高価な部屋が存在しているんですけど
この建物壊れると この大事な高価な部屋が幽霊になってどこかに逃げていくんですかね
入れられないんだから
他のところに幽霊として行きましょうと
ないでしょう そのまま消える
そこでさらに考えてみると
すべてのすべてのものは現象なんです
マイクロフォンの鉄も現象であって
プラスチックの部品も現象であって
服の場合は糸も現象でしょ
糸もまた別なものから出てきて出てくるものだから
例えば化学製品のね 化繊だったら単なる化学
化学物質でしょうに 粉とか液体とか
綿のものだったらただの綿の細いあれでしょうね
だからあくまでもどこまで見ても現象
実体見つからないんですね
現象っていうのは長持ちはしません
すぐ潰れてしまいます
だからマイクロフォンなんかは長持ちはしません
すぐもう潰れてしまいます
シャボン玉と同じ シャボン玉もあるんだけど
あれはあの石鹸のおかげで
水では水がちょっとつなげておいてつなげてしまうんですね
いわゆるこのまあ 日本語もわかる言葉はちょっとわかりませんけど
なんとか化学的な言葉ありますけど
このサーフェステンションと英語で言いますけど
このその表面的にお互いに引っ張るエネルギーが出て
その中に空気が入っちゃって
それぐらいのことで それでちょっとしたことで
温度を変えただけでも
ほんのわずかな変化でパッとはじけちゃうんです
それで大事な きれいな
美しいあのシャボン玉がどこに行ったんでしょうかとかね
どこに行ったんですかね
もともともいたわけじゃないし
はじけたところでどこに行ったわけでもない
ただの現象 だからこの体もたった一つの現象
この心もたった瞬間の現象
今 今楽しいと思っても
次の瞬間で違う条件によって気持ち悪いと
それで一生気持ち悪いかというとそうでもない
他のちょっとしたことでまた違う気持ち
この部屋は暖かいな 気持ちいいなと思ったっても
外に出たときにあー寒いよ寒いとなっちゃうでしょうに
だから暖かい気持ちいい
寒い 気持ち悪いってことでなるでしょうに
だからあなたの心はどんな
どんな調子かとハッキリしなさいと私は怒ったってもどうにもならないでしょうに
あんた この部屋の中ですごい気持ちよくいたでしょうに
なんでバス停で立ってる時はそんなに気持ち悪く立ってますかと
あんた一体どんな性格ですか？と私は怒っても意味がないでしょう
その条件で その条件で心が変わるんです
だから心も現象 体も現象
それからだから実体もない
だから変わっていく どれぐらい時間持ちますか？ということは
この現象の原因によります
シャボン玉はもう一分
一秒だったら最高 一秒持てば
まあこういうふうなもう硬いものできている現象は
それなりに何年間持つでしょうとかね
で この体はもっと早く壊れていきますけど
やっぱり生き物だから
壊れるたびに毎日 だから一日三回召し上がっているでしょう
激しく体が壊れているんです
これもそんなに何もしなくても
かなり１０年でも持てます
体は一日二日も持てません
壊れてガラガラと壊れちゃうんです
だからずっともう材料を入れっぱなし
壊れるたびにこちらから補給する
補給する 補給する だから我々は一分何回呼吸していますかね
ね 考えてください 外の物質
どれぐらい入れ替えていますかと
そこで食べ物を食べて
一日三回食べて それから間食もして
もういろんなことをして
とにかくもうそれに一生かかっちゃうんですね
皆様に生きる暇がないんです
壊れかけている体に品物を補給することだって精いっぱいです
いわゆる修理するはするはするは終わりがない
生まれた瞬間から修理始めるんです
人間が それで死ぬ瞬間まで修理工場
生きてる 生きて生きている暇も余裕ないんです
だから体はすごい激しく壊れていきます
だから壊れ方のスピードっていうのは
まあそのその現象によります
花だったら 1 日で枯れる場合もあるし
1週間で枯れる場合もあるし
地球はまあ何千万年も持つでしょう
でも国々はもっと短いでしょ
命は潰れちゃうんですね
山とかはまたもっと命が短い
潰れてしまう その上で生きている我々はものすごい
もう瞬間で消えてしまう
そうやってこの現象の命っていうのは寿命と言うんですけど
それはそのそのものによってまあ違いますけどね
犬の一生は 15年であって
人間の一生はまあ 90年ぐらいでしょうしね
でもあの昆虫の一生はまあ 1ヶ月とか 3ヶ月とか 1週間とかね
でも一つ一つは完璧な寿命そのものですけどね
それで心さえ現象です
時々私はあ 怒ったと言うでしょ
この怒りも現象なんです
何かがなかったら生まれません
あ 楽しいと思った途端
それ何かがなかったら楽しくならないんです
だからそれも現象です
ああ 考えましたと言うでしょうね
それも現象です 何かなかったら考えません
そこで私がいるんだ 私には霊魂があるんだと思ってるでしょ
それ何かがあってそう思ってるだけで現象です
故に霊魂も現象 魂も現象
体も現象 心も現象 ことごとく全てが現象です
現象ということは 生地と糸とみたいな感じで
結局は何もないと 現象だからこそ変化する
変化するんだからこそ実体はない
故にドッカと言うんです
それであの方程式みたいな言葉がありまして
ヤングカンキー ヤングヤダヤングアニチャンタンドカンというと
ヤングアニチャン アニチャンというのは無常ということで
で まあまあ 文字通りに読めばヤダニッチャンなんですけど
まあまあ これこれ学者いっぱいいるんだからもう喋りにくくなってますけどね
まあだから とにかくこのヤダ
ヤンアニッチャン 無常なるものはタン
これはドゥッカン苦であると
だから変化するんだということなんです
苦ということは  これ日本どう訳すればいいんでしょうかね
まあ無常だから苦であるというふうに考えた方がやりやすいですけどね
それで納得いかない方々は
もう厳密に日本訳をしてもらった方がいいんですけど
私にはちょっとこういう言葉
日本語できませんだけど Whatever
is impermanent, it is suffering. というふうな英訳になりますけどね
いわゆる無常だから苦だよと
無常たるものは苦になりますと
苦と言えますと それぐらいの単純日本語なんです
日本語で言う ですから
逆に言えば お釈迦様はドッカドッカと言ったのは
すべてのものは変化していくんだという意味なんです
何でも変化するんだよと
止まってはいません それなんです
それはすごい真理なんです
だってみんな止まっていると勘違いしてるでしょ
あとは試しにでも 今この部屋電気ついてますか？はい
そうでしょって思ってるでしょうに
変でしょ その答えは 光が止まってるわけじゃないでしょうに
ずっと変化して流れている
でも私たちははい ここに部屋があります
ここに光があります とか
さっさと平気で簡単で言ってしまっちゃいますが
そんなあるということじゃない
ずっと流れて変わっていくんです
だからサンカーラだから現象だからどうせ消える
その消えることにお釈迦様は大した意味がない
そんなもうそんなに真剣に考える必要はないという意味で
ドッカとむなしいと言うんです
ああ そう そんなのかという意味なんですよ
例えば すごいバカでかい綺麗なシャボン玉を作ったところで
えらくびっくりしたんだと
あまりにも綺麗で ただそれだけでしょ
すぐパッとはじけるんだから
シャボン玉だからどうったことはないと
すべてのものは無常だから
まあどうったことはない
という意味でドッカと言うんです
ですから 皆様方は現象論を理解するか
あるいは人生からすべての誰がどういうふうに生きていたっても
ミミズと競争すればどちらが勝つかと言えないんだと
アメリカの大統領と自分の庭の植木鉢の下にいるミミズと
どちらが偉いとか それぐらいのものだと
生きるということは そうやって考えるか
あるいはすべては変化していくんだと無常で考えるか
無常ということはすごい大変な真理で
簡単単純な真理ではないんです
だから ものがあるということは
ものが変化するんだということで
動いているんだということで
例えば私は喋ってるでしょ
だから音あるでしょ 音はあるということは
私はずっと無常で 口から音を出していることで
出した出した音はその瞬間
その瞬間で消えるんです
だから音があるんです
もし音が永遠だったら
私は一言葉喋ろうと思った途端
その音で永久的に音で諸相すると
もう喋れなくなっちゃうんですね
あまりにも音がありすぎて消えませんでしょ
そんな世界はないんだからね
そう大変なこと それだったら我々現れることは何もできません
音が出た それでずっとその音があるんです
結構うるさくはなります
その時は ですから 音が出てくる
それは消えていく 出てくるは消えてる
出てきて消えていく それで私たちは音がある
この人喋ってるか あの人歌ってる
って言うんです だから無常だから生きているんでしょうし
無常だから成り立っている
だから存在イコール無常なんです
あるイコール無常なんです
まあ一応あるという言葉がありますね
だからそこは誰もわかってなかったんだから
永遠な話語るでしょうし
永遠な天国とか話してるんですね
そこでお釈迦様 ああ この方々は科学者ではない
単なる無知の塊であると
永遠って成り立ちませんと
永遠イコール無常なんです
変化することなんです
だからこの無常というものはよく理解してみてくださいと
人間の悩み苦しみは無常に逆らうんだからなんです
病気になったってもまあいいんじゃないんです
それで それ嫌と思うのは
私は病気になるはずではありませんと思うんだからなんです
旦那が死んでも 奥さんが死んでも
子供がもう二 三歳で死んじゃってもいいでしょう
それで でもなんでそれが悲しいんですかね
死ぬべきではなかったからでしょ
だから無常に逆らうんだから
すごい ものすごいきつい悲しみが生まれてきます
例えばもう八十歳のおばあちゃん死んじゃったら
まあちょっと二日間は悲しいと
それで忘れちゃいますけど
でも自分の四歳の子供が死んじゃったら
二日間では忘れられませんね
なぜかというと おばあちゃんの場合は
まあそれほどきつく 絶対死なないということはなかったんですね
まあいてほしい 長生きしてほしいという気持ちはありました
元気で長生きと長生きしてほしい
それなのに八十歳で消えちゃった
だから悲しかったんですね
ああ 悲しいと でも二日で忘れちゃう
だから悲しみが少ない
それで自分の四歳の子供が死んじゃった
そうすると自分が怒れるほど悲しくなっちゃうんです
なぜかというと 死ぬはずではなかったでしょ
そんなはずっていうのはありますかね
すべて無常だから お金がなくなったら悲しいでしょ
なんでしょうかね お金がなくなるはずではなかったんです
なんで家に帰ると家に泥棒が入ってるんです
そうすると怯えて怖くなって
慌てて走り回ったりして
警察に行ったりするんですかね
泥棒に入られて品物を持っていったら
自分がすごく悲しむんです
あの悲しみはどこから生まれてくるかというと
泥棒が入るはずではなかったんですね
このはずが 大変な苦しみは
そこをはずってないんです
何でもありだからね 無常の世界で家を作っても潰れるし
潰れたら潰れたところで悲しかったら
その人は潰れないだろうと仮定したんですね
だから病気になったら悲しくなっちゃうと
体が痛いのは別な話で
病気になったら体が痛い
それで終わり お釈迦様の体も痛かった
お釈迦様にも でもそれ苦しかったわけじゃないんです
ただ体痛い ですから 我々は病気になったら体痛いだけではなくて
すごい苦しいんですね
それが病気になるはずじゃないんだからなんです
人が死んじゃったらなぜ悲しいかというと
死ぬはずじゃないんだからなんです
そんなことあり得ますか？この世の中で
それほどバカな人間いるんですかね
目の前で何でも変化していくにも関わらず
よくよくも自分のことにだけ無常を否定するでしょ
人のことだったら平気で
例えば南アメリカで台風でもう400人死にましたと
ああそう それで終わるんですね
平気で ああそう そんなこと聞いてる暇がないよと言って
自分がもうジャガイモの皮を剥くんです 400
人以上死んでるんだけど
自分にはジャガイモの皮を剥くこと大事でしょうに
それで誰かがあんたの子供
あんな階段で転がっちゃって怪我してるんだよと言ったら
ジャガイモの皮を剥くどころか
もうガスもあれも消さないで
病院にそれてよく家に帰ると家が火事になってるとかありますから
なんでその時だけあれほど慌てるんですかね
やっぱり人の無常だったらどうでもいいんです
認めるの偉そうに ああ
そんなことは世の中で
台風っていうのはね 自然現象だから
そんなどうにもならないんだよと
でも悲しいでしょ あれほど人をいっぺんに
そんな人っていうのはね
いくらでも死にますからね
生まれたんだったら死ななくちゃいけないんだよと偉そうなこと言うでしょうね
ついでに言いますけど
あなたの子供 今階段で転がっちゃって怪我してるんだと
あ そう とんでもないと
もうそこに飛び上がっちゃうんです
だから見てください 我々の生き方っていうのは
無常っていうのは分かったようなふりをしているんだけど
私に対しては認めませんと
それで苦しみを味わっちゃうんです
お釈迦様は答えは簡単です
あなたも無常だよと あなたは無常だよと
それだけ それを理解すれば
もう心は清らかになって解脱を体験できます
ですから ドゥッカっていうのは絶対的
すごい素晴らしい真理なんです
それほどすごい真理がないんで
なぜ真理かというと 嘘じゃないんだから
誰にもこれだけは違いますよと誰にも言うことできません
それだけで真理に価値あるわけじゃないんです
皆様方はもうものすごい科学を勉強なさってるでしょう
私みたいにぐうたら坊主でも
ただパーリ語しか勉強してない
頭悪いわけじゃないでしょうね
数学やら科学やら何でも知ってるでしょうね
それでもアインじゃなくて
アインシュタインですね
まあ相対性理論やら まあすごいことを発見しましたと
思うでしょ？アインシュタインの相対論とお釈迦様の無常論と
どちらが価値ありますかね
アインシュタインの相対性理論を勉強して
心清らかになった人が一人でもいますか？人生の苦しみなくなった人が一人でもいますか？それでもって何を獲得してるんですか？ただえらいこっちゃ
それだけでしょうに だからそれとミミズの知識と何が違いますか
ミミズは土の中で何を食べられるかというぐらいのことを知っていて
アインシュタインは相対
光はもう曲がねじ曲がっちゃうんだ
だからもう違うところで見えるんだとかね
物の存在っていうのはそうやってスピードによって変わるんだとかね
だから何でしょうかね
それで だから体が外の世界いじってるだけで
心はいじってないんですね
だからアインシュタインの相対論で
たとえ幼稚園の子供二人の喧嘩さえもなくすことはできません
どんなもう原子について
もうどんな核兵器作る
どんな人にしたっても
そういう学問的な科学的な真理
スバルの望遠鏡からした見た宇宙の世界の知恵で
幼稚園で子供二人がやり合ってるんで
それ直せますかと 仲直りできますかね
だから役に立ちますかね
そんなことで でも子供が風船が割っちゃった
この子 こいつは割っちゃったんだよと言って
もう喧嘩するときは あのね
風船っていうのはもうこいつ割らなくたっても
お前もそれ割っちゃいますよと
そんなものは割れるようにできてるんだと
それぐらいわからない
よくもあんたバカではないかと
一緒に遊べと言ったら遊んでくれるでしょ
それぐらいのことで あんた割れない風船見たことありますかと
幼稚園の子供に聞いてみてください
そう言われたら 瞬時に子供が泣き止めるんです
喧嘩もやめるんです だから無常ということがそうやって人生に一切での答えを教えてくれるんです
それでこの真理を知ったんだから
お釈迦様の心から一切の煩悩が消えてしまったんです
一切の無明は消えてしまったんです
一切欲しがる気持ち あれ知りたい
これ知りたい これやりたい
あれやりたいという この限りない人間のこの走り回ることなくなっちゃったんです
それでお釈迦様も我々と同じく出口のない
迷路の中にいたんです
お釈迦様は他の人をあっちこち走り回ってる人よ
バカみたいに それはしなかったんです
とにかく出口がないんだから
途中で死ぬでしょうと
それでもう一人の人はボケーとして寝ていたでしょうね
それを見て こいつも役に立ちません
ただボケーと寝ているだけだから
そのまま死んでしまっちゃうよと
お釈迦様は考えたんです
出口見つかろうと走り回ったっても意味がない
バカみたくボケーとして寝たって意味がない
一旦この壁を登ってみようと
壁を登ってみたんです
それ出口です 出口でしょ
まあですから無常を知れば
問題に 人生に答えが出てくる
で ドッカを知れば この生きる目的は手に入るんです
そうでない限りは みんな手ぶらで永久的に走るんです
一度も人生のゴールには達しません
だから 生きることのゴールに達するためには
ドッカというその一言葉を理解する必要があるんです
で 話はそこら辺で終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]